diese geschichte beginnt am rheinfall
und diese geschichte beginnt
grammatikalisch nicht ganz korrekt denn
hier frage ich mich immer wieder sind
wir auf diesen christoph blocher
hereingefallen
mit dieser teuflischen frage beginne ich
bei pfarrer gerhard locker mit seinem
bruder christoph direkt am rheinfall
aufgewachsen ist wie das getöse des
wassers einen fürs leben trägt will mit
verbrochen vorexerziert
der reva der rutsche
und so singt der folgenden akkord
[Musik]
das übrigens natürlich den usa
und fritz katers ohne bliebe
moment halt noch fertig machen so ist da
wie ist das mit dem auftrag für bluter
christoph risch also auf sylt wo sie
immer das häufig muss raich hat das
bereit ist ein bisschen recht
strategische stratege hatte daher es für
der macht sie auch nie anders der hätten
auftrag geht eine muss deshalb hügel
bush im sitzen aber so seiner band room
flüge um und so er machte sich die
strategie aber zuerst und dieses sehe
schon vorher hohen zog und das gibt eine
strategie aber die strategie ich immer
mein ziel unterworfen auftrag
schon in den ersten minuten wird klar
die branche sprache ist eine
kriegerische blocher sehen das leben als
riesiges schlachtfeld
[Musik]
a
klangschön in stuben zeiten wie jetzt
telefonieren gerhard und christoph fast
täglich miteinander
sie sehen ich bloß brüder sondern brüder
im geiste
wir wollen den logischen horizont etwas
näher betrachten und beginnen am
äußersten zipfel der schweiz in halle wo
gerhard locker bis zur pensionierung
reformierter pfarrer herum
gemeindepräsident waren
also eu land und das ist schweizer land
das gebiet wo sie da eine gesehnt das
ist wonach sony beschuldigt mit dem
schluss die prognose günstig das ist vor
berlin konturiert und kommandiert wenn
sie sich und redet und das tal
abkommandiert um kontrolliert wobei er
vor allem junge tagesschau fuß sondern
kino antwortzeit verstand vor hallo an
erster stelle steht
hallo hallo recht bricht bundesrecht
seit jahrhunderten sagt christoph
blocher hielt an dieses jahr hier oben
eine provokative ersten -august-rede
volksrecht steht vor völkerrecht war
darin die parole von bundesrat blocher
ganz im sinn und geist seines großen
bruders gerhard farblich liebt es wenn
ihm sein kleiner bruder in sachen
granaten werfen in nichts nachsteht
er war es der ganze saal veräußerer
schweizerische politik ausruhen
opera fertigbringt 30
ob er war fertig bringt das überstürzte
langguth das wo es uns schmerzt werde
das was ich den song mäßig muss erwähnt
werden dass jede politik und politiker
sie und in der politik in der
politischen stimmung selbstverständlich
und osteuropa und sie haben verstanden
wird nur dann dass wir beabsichtigen
dass der puls bald mein bruder christoph
ist das natürlich etwas anderes
er könne sich nicht an einen pfosten er
hat einen auftrag und schon bald hängt
der svp general als parteisoldat
verkleidet an jeder straßenecke
[Applaus]
sie markiert durch ihre blüten sehr viel
geld kostet jetzt nämlich wundern woher
kommt das glaubt 15 millionen zu testen
meines wissen sie wenn ihr steht der
sind sagen sie wissen wir viel zu offen
redet mit mir über sieben jahre
krankheit reden und über mini akademie
soll jetzt immer nur über also beide und
des landes angelegenheit
bei den wahlen nur noch ein thema noch
ja oder nein
und alle parteien machten mit ist also
die ganze politik auf diesem blog
hereingefallen war blocher ist beglückt
ob des svp hilflos und fernsehstudio
mischte sich unter die elefanten water
ist war sie doch gerne bruch weiß
eigentlich schon bald hören werden
hier gibt es eine politische zukunft
das ist jetzt einfach nicht einfach
große wahlverlierer sp-präsident
hans-jürg fehr wie gerd locher kommt
auch aus dem schaffhausischen
einfach nicht aus
von politischer verbrechen und so
schnell gar nicht also und rechtlicher
dummkopf
in seiner schwäbischen verlauf dramas
kann oma vom hochintellektuellen endlich
haben wir sofort ist sich fragen um die
lauferei ist ein heimsieg mit
jetzt gibt das blocher lachen
diabolische helmig um zum vorschein
es läuft einem kalt den rücken runter
die zuschauerinnen und zuschauer und
elefanten darunter der schweizer
parteipräsidenten und mit fast 30
prozent wähleranteil ist die blockpartei
sieg obwohl bis zum mehrheit noch ein
schöner teil fehlt steht der höhenrausch
futter türen sich uli maurer gibt sie
ganz schön sein weiß er schon was die
blockes mit dem vorhaben dass sie irgend
erforderlichen rumänisch stelle dass sie
irgendwas ultimatum stellen dass die
häufigen großer kulisse für ein
vierjahres und nicht vor nach dem
resultat mehr stöhnt zur konkurrenz das
land schweiz kann nur in konkurrenz
regiert werden und besonders sich nicht
möglich alle spekulationen wurden in ein
anderes wichtig wird die schweiz nicht
wiederbringen das heißt einzelne tiere
verteilt das bild aus dem bundesrat nach
wie vor nötig sind bereiten mit sagt um
einige meter konkurrenz regieren also
bin ich schwer
für die vor allem bei patenten toll
der autor ist langsam reifenprofil sie
gerungen
[Applaus]
dieser sieg war und der niederlage
und die werden am besten wie
parteipräsident werden von der svp und
bundespräsident ad dt
das wird denn da ist ja das problem
erich dem landesüblichen gültigen
niemand
weit über rufen ist eine deutsche
skifahrer blocher flüstert mir noch zu
dass es die chance der schweiz wäre
könnte bruder christoph reichere debatte
mente übernehmen
vor vier jahren an jenem denkwürdigen
zehnten dezember reiste gerhard bruch
ins bundeshaus um seinem bruder bei der
bundesratswahl beizustehen
beim eintritt in die heiligen hallen
friedlich verbrochen
die atmosphäre sei kalt und vor allem
nirgends werte gelacht
die e3 enthüllt werden
gerhard schaut auf seinen kleinen bruder
herunter
gewählt ist mit 121 stimmen hat der
nationalrat christoph loos
[Applaus]
silvia blogger jetzt bundesrats cutting
woche wurde gewählt um ihn einzubinden
da ist das parlament wohl hereingefallen
[Applaus]
sicher unglaublich sein ist die absolut
unmögliche tatsache ich würde mich kein
wort hat sie eine trockene haut
obwohl wir glauben aber unmöglich ist
das tränen
mit den flocken
wie lange hält
er ist mein seelsorge sagt christopher
gerhard war blocher ist der einzige dem
sich der bundesrat am vertrag eines ihm
schlecht geht und wenn sie einen gegner
aus lachen können stecken die blüte
gerne unter einer decke
[Musik]
die rewe touristik wenn sie vor vier
jahren nach geschlagenen schlacht bockt
gernhardt wochen bundesrats blutend am
boden am fuß einer langen treppe
bioland begrüßt
wien für politischen clique
ihr sohn weise bleibt die kriegen ihn in
krakau da machen wir unendlich glücklich
in rheinhausen die blochers ausgleich
nichts wie das wasser das auch nicht
frage ob es unterstützen soll oder nicht
muss er tun was er tun müsse sagt bruder
gerhard über christoph
[Musik]
und dann verrät er mir noch wissen zu
und her geht
das bundeshaus ist also die ganze
bundesregierung ist verlieren mit
wichtig mit teil methodisch camera raw
bloß so dünne schließlich mit rufus
extremfall und du bist ob du hast hast
du der kampf gegen die wichtig für heißt
alles kann und alles beherrscht flüge
schwere artillerie panzer als es
verbraucht heißt es schwer für uns
gerichtet nie passiert denn hier habe
ich wenn du gehörst du mir heute ist der
nachteil wenn ihr ausflügen nicht
entspannt sondern weniger staat ist
einzigartig
un denn mit den menschen getötet
das heißt noch kampf das heißt blut
jetzt bist du in der lage dazu tragen
und bist du in der arktis denn die dient
jetzt behaupte wien vielleicht hat ja
die andere ausmaße und wenn ihr merkt
dass du so schnell wie ziehe das
aufführen
und wenn sie ist die form können sie das
mit der tag ist es sogar auf dich los
der treibstoff mehr zeit hätte ich doch
nur zeit sie stets was ist das da machen
jetzt nach vier jahren vielleicht eine
rolle sagt meistercup und hilft die
jetzt bereits von osaka seit 18
ein drittel von der herzog braucht aber
sie einst uwe riese
und wenn dieser reich die tanke heinz
merkt er gar eine kraftkur stoße
bei diesem kriegerischen weltbild kommt
irgendwann die peinliche frage sind wir
nicht doch auf diese blochers
hereingefallen
[Musik]
neben dem rheinfall sind die brüder
aufgewachsen vater woche war hier
pfarrer als fundamentalistische prediger
wurde vater blogger entlassen
trotz einer elfköpfigen kinderschar
[Musik]
er hat als autoritär hat bloss einmal
müsse ich rief nämlich unter christoph
dach zusätzlich erklärt hat er gegen die
zlg sie betonte dass nrw pur während
tempo rk sec hat der vater hielt
antwortet es folgen fußraum jetzt hast
du tour wert und jetzt sage dir du wirst
spur
das spüre ich aber gerade enthusiasmus
natürlich kritik und dann hängt je zwei
camps und das erste chance sie oder
riecht oft gehört und ich steh nicht was
dann folgte ist das moderne märchen vom
bauern knecht der milliardenschwere
unternehmer in den bundesrat einziehen
ein musterbrief wäre
wir müssen im bundesrat ist und man sich
oft er werde denn die entsprechend
niedrig
nach ein paar wochen zurück wirkt das
deine gott und nach ein paar meter hoch
1 gemerkt dass sechs historische
richtigen fragen ist aber der ist oft
der fall ist
bei der bundesratswahl seines bruders
vor vier jahren hieß gerhard
zusammengebrochen so groß waren seine
erwartungen in christoph er hoffte dass
der kleine bruder das steuer herumreißen
würde
doch heute ist nicht mehr die frage was
hat er erreicht was ist noch zu tun
wichtig ist nur noch drin zu bleiben
[Musik]
auch als großvater sind christoph von
gerhard noch immer die kleinen frechen
buben im sandkasten
auch wenn sich bundesrat blocher immer
auf seine nähe zum fußvolk beruf der
politische erfolg der wirtschaftliche
reichtum und die ungeheure prominenz
haben aus dem kleinen bauen ein großes
tier gemacht sagt er unbedingt die jetzt
blieb und warum also der erfolg ist
ziemlich alles falsch er unbedingt
überhaupt nicht also mission soll sich
harmonisch betrifft eher klein
unbedingte wille karriere
ihr müsst die bundesanwälte bundesrat
oder er will und um wirklich sondern er
hat müsse mit dem rief alle lotto frage
doch wollte rief er muss ja einfach
natürlich muss dann wieder so die
definition was ich die menschliche
freiheit die menschliche freiheit
besteht nicht darin dass man tun und
lassen kann was man will sondern dass
man das wollen kann was man muss und
vereinigten holzfäller warten gespannt
ob ihre strategie im bundesrat erneut
auf geht die politik symbol des ortes
die junge sie infrage stellt hat oder
frankreich ließen sie das heißt dass er
viel geld kostet kann sie direkt oder
seine zahlungen ein
der frühere stuttgarter balletts an ein
aber das kind über huntloser so wahr
machen wird sie wurden die fahrbahnen
revolution geld immer irgendwo in eine
position wäre möglich halbzeit für die
wenn ich gewählt werde würde unser
unternehmen auf und kasse bringen und
der grünen und der partei zur
komposition wie stark wie noch in
unserem staat umbauen und wie viel macht
wird er übernehmen
wie schafft es blocher überhaupt heute
schon in einem system das darauf beruht
dass nicht eine reine allzu viel macht
hat zurück nach cala d'or timo guerra
blocher zuflucht gefunden hat nachdem er
wie sein vater schon aus scharfer
prediger entlassen wurde
auch am äußersten zipfel der schweiz
bewegt jetzt die frage geht die
bundesratswahl nächste woche so über die
bühne wie sich das die bruches
ausgerechnet haben
immer wieder kommen die blockes auf den
auftrag zu sprechen
doch wer den auftrag erteilt diese
antwort bleibt pfarrer woche schuldig
foto gerhard hat eigentlich schuld dass
christoph blocher einer der reichsten
männer der schweiz wurde er hat den
damals nahezu mittellosen christoph
geradezu gedrängt die ems chemie zu
übernehmen
das ist also ein sehr zentrales thema
mit dem wir ständig konfrontiert wert
wenn man ihm vorwirft
der segen macht wenn und im privaten zu
game and also ich fand im letzten a
ich weiß von einer verfall haid an das
geld das ist einfach ein netter kumpel
seine magie sondern mehr die hälfte
richtung daran wie ich also wir werden
natürliche abwehr und ich glaube nicht
dass die halt schweiz zu liefern
[Applaus]
also sie sehen die menschen sie sind
also grundsätzlich niedrig wo waren sie
aber das eine komische situation
es braucht ja oft bei christoph ist das
ein märchenhaft reichtums gemüt hat
blocher ein paar milliarden beschert
seien einmalige reichtum seiner erfolge
und seine macht müssen doch zu einem
höhenrausch führen
und da ist es nicht mehr weit diese auch
christoph blocher auf sich selbst
hereinfällt
vielleicht ist alles ein ganz großer
irrtum viele hund eines tages aus dass
er und seine frau und seine freundin als
engagierter hinterher
aber wir großartige bietet sage was ich
sage dir ein weiß denn was verrät sie
als es runter werken oder wenn er es
merkt
er muss sagen ich war nie etwas anderes
als ein versager da gibt es wenig halt
dauer eine ende und so sind wir am ende
dieser geschichte gleich weit wie am
anfang
am rheinfall und beim reinfahren was
vielleicht mehr was ein fotografisches
problem ist
[Musik]